we've learned in previous videos that
relative to the orbital plane around the
Sun or the plane of Earth's orbit around
the Sun the earth has a certain tilt so
let me draw the earth's tilt relative to
that orbital plane right over here so
this if this is the orbital plane right
over here so we're looking right
directly sideways on this orbital plane
right sideways along this orbital plane
that I've drawn in orange and maybe at
the point in Earth's orbit right now
maybe the Sun is to the left and so the
Rays from the Sun are coming in this
general direction we've learned that
Earth has a certain tilt earth has a
tilt and what I mean that it means if
you think about the the axis around
which it's rotating it's not straight up
from the orbital plane it is at an angle
and let me draw that so if I want to
draw an arrow that's coming out of the
North Pole it would look like that and
maybe the odd I'll draw an arrow coming
out of the South Pole and the earth is
rotating in that direction right over
here and you notice this axis that I'm
that I've drawn this arrow on it is not
straight up and down and right now it is
an angle it is an angle it is at an
angle of it is at an angle of 23 23
point four degrees with the vertical
width being straight up and down and
we've learned how this is what is the
primary cause of our seasons in that
when the northern hemisphere is pointed
towards the Sun it's getting a
disproportionate amount of the solar
radiation whatever is going through the
atmosphere has to go through less
atmosphere and the things in the
northern hemisphere are getting more
daylight and when you go into the when
you when the earth is on the other side
of the Sun and it the northern
hemisphere is pointed away from the Sun
then the opposite is going to happen and
the reverse is true for the southern
hemisphere but in that video when we
talk about how tilt can affect how tilt
can affect the seasons I also kind of
hinted a little bit that this is the
current tilt right now and over long
periods of time that this tilt will
change and in particular it will
very and even the boundaries for this
varying will are different than for the
past million years and they will be for
the next million years but it varies
roughly between twenty two point one
degrees and twenty four point five
degrees and just to make it clear that
it's not going it's not wobbling back
and forth like this and just to
visualize twenty-two point one versus
twenty four point five it's not a huge
difference so this is twenty three point
four and I'm not measuring exactly
maybe pointing in this direction may be
pointing may be pointing in that maybe
twenty two point one would look
something like that in fact I have
exaggerated it and maybe twenty four
point five would go look something like
that and so it's not a huge difference
but it is enough of a difference so we
believe to actually have a a significant
impact on what the climate is like or
what the seasons are like especially in
terms of how the how how much of a
chance different parts of our of our
planet have a chance to freeze over and
not freeze over and all the rest or how
much sunlight they get in all the rest
so it has some impact but I want to make
it clear that it takes a long period of
time that it actually takes 41,000 years
to go from a minimum tilt to a maximum
tilt and then back to a minimum tilt
41,000 years and right now at a tilt of
23 point four degrees where someplace
right smack in between and we we think
the last minimum the the or started the
last maximum was that was it 8700 BCE
before the Common Era or you could say
before Christ and that the next minimum
when our tilt has been minimized the
next time our tilt will be minimized
will be will be at at eleven thousand
the year eleven thousand eight hundred
so this isn't something that's happening
overnight but it is something that could
affect our climate over long periods of
time and this is just one factor and
sometimes this changing of the tilt a
fancy word for tilt is sometimes given
is Oh Big O blick WA t o blick WA T but
this is really just a fancy word for
tilt this this changing of the obliquity
or changing of the tilt is one of these
chain
changes in Earth's rotation or Earth's
orbit around the Sun that might have
long-term cycles or effects on Earth's
climate and maybe they do help cause
certain ice ages when they when they act
it together with each other over certain
cycles and broadly this entire class of
cycles are called Milankovitch cycles
Milankovitch use a serbian scientist
who's the guy who theorized that these
changes in earth's orbit might be
responsible for long-term climate change
or maybe some cycles where we enter ice
ages and get out of ice ages or we have
more extreme or less extreme weather so
these are Milankovitch Milankovitch
Milankovitch cycles and changes in the
tilt or the obliquity are just one of
the possible factors playing into
Milankovitch cycles and what i want to
do in this video in the next view is
talk about all of the different factors
or at least summarize all of the
different factors now another one this
one is pretty intuitive for me that this
tilt can change one that's a little bit
less intuitive when you first think
about it is something called precession
and i've precession precession and the
idea behind precession i guess the best
analogy I can think of is if you imagine
a top or maybe you can imagine earth as
a top right over here the top is
spinning the top is spinning in this
direction and oblique WA t tells you
essentially how much it's wobbling well
actually we think of it this way
imagine a wobbling top so it's rotating
like this it's tilted and then it's also
it is also it is also if you imagine
that this was a pole up here that's
coming out of the pole if this was
actually a physical arrow that that
arrow itself that arrow itself would be
rotating so what you the best way to
think about it is a wobbling top if you
think if it's after some point of time
this thing would wobble so it would look
like so it would look like this
so now the arrow is pointing that way
and if you wait a few more seconds now
maybe the arrow I mean now maybe the
arrow is pointing a little bit out of
the page and then you wait a few more
seconds then it's pointing in this
direction there's pointing into the page
and so this whole time the oblique
isn't changing the obliquity you can
kind of view it as how far how far is
that wobble you could imagine how far
from vertical is that wobble and no
matter where we are in that rotation it
hasn't changed and you can imagine it as
the precession as where we are in the
wobble where we are in the wobble and I
want to this is a little bit hard to
visualize and hopefully as we think
about it in different ways and I draw
different diagrams it'll make it a
little bit clearer but I want to make it
clear just as just as it takes a long
time for the for the inclination to
change from a minimum value to a maximum
value in back it takes a huge amount of
time for Earth's precession to change in
a significant way so for this top two
kind of four if you imagined this this
arrow popping out for this arrow to
actually trace out an entire loop it
takes 26,000 years so 26,000 years to
have an entire cycle of precession now
what I want to do is think about given
that this precession is occurring I want
to think about how that would affect our
seasons or how it would actually affect
how we think about the year or the
calendar so let's draw the orbit of
Earth around the Sun so here is my Sun
right over here and here is the orbit of
Earth and I'm not going to think too
much I'm going to assume that it's
almost circular for the sake of this
video in future videos we'll talk about
how the eccentricity or how elliptical
the orbit is can also affect the
Milankovitch cycles or play into the
Milankovitch cycles but let's just draw
the orbit of Earth let's let me just
draw the orbit of Earth around the Sun
over here and so you can imagine this is
at one point in time this is the earth
let's say it is let's say it is tilted
towards the Sun right now so it is
tilted towards the Sun and so if in the
northern hemisphere and I'm assuming
this arrows coming out of the North Pole
this would be the summer in the Northern
Hemisphere and then if you had no
precession absolutely no precession when
you go to this time of year
you still have the same direction of
tilt you
say you still have let me do that in
blue you still have the same the same
direction of tilt we're still pointing
to the same part of the universe we
still have the same Northstar you go to
this time we're still tilting in the
same direction relative to the universe
but we're not tilting away from the Sun
and now this would be the winter in the
northern hemisphere and we'd keep going
around if you had no procession when you
get back to this point over here we'd be
tilting in the exact same direction you
mean if you're if you're if your oblique
WA T or your change if your tilt changed
a little bit you might move up or down
away or towards the Sun a little bit but
this is all assuming no precession now
I'm going to think about what happens if
you do have precession so what's
happening with precession is when you go
around one time around the Sun by the
time you get to this point again you're
not pointing at exactly the same
direction you are now pointing a little
bit further so this arrow this let me
draw a little bit bigger so this is the
earth and this is that arrow and this is
hard to visualize or at least it's hard
for me to visualize well once you get it
it's easier to visualize but the first
time I tried to understand it it was
hard for me to understand how precession
was different than obliquity or
different than tilt oh blick WA T is how
much we're going from from vertical and
so if we had no precession we would be
exactly pointing in that same direction
every year now if we with just
precession alone what happens is every
year this this arrow is slowly tracing
out a circle slowly tracing out a circle
that goes like this so I'm going to
exaggerate how much it's happening just
so that you can visualize it so maybe
after several years that arrow is not
when you're at that same point relative
to the Sun that same point in the solar
system that arrow is no longer pointing
in that direction it is now traced out a
little bit of that circle so it is now
pointing it is now pointing in this
direction it is now pointing in this
direction so if it is now pointing in
this direction will that same point in
the solar system that same point
relative to the Sun that same exact
point of the orbit will it still be the
the the summer in the Northern
Hemisphere well it won't because we're
now not pointing directly or we're not
most inclined to the Sun at that point
now we would have been most inclined to
the Sun a little bit earlier in the year
or a little bit earlier in the orbit so
we would have been most inclined to the
Sun we would have been most inclined the
Sun may be over here may be over here
and it would take a many many many
actual thousands of years for it to get
to be 2/4 for the procession to change
this much but then over here this is
where when at this point in that year
when when we would be pointed most
towards the Sun so what the the real
effect of precession is is doing to our
seasons and doing to what our sense of
what our year is is that every year
relative to our orbit on earth because
earth is kind of a top that's slowly
circling the slowly tracing out this
circle with I guess you could say with
it's pole what it's doing is is it's
making it it's making it tilt towards
the Sun or away from the Sun a little
bit earlier each year a little bit
earlier I know it's hard to visualize
but you can even take a top out and have
I don't know have a basketball as the
Sun and if you play with it you'll see
how that works and the precession is
another one of those factors that affect
that that play into I should say the
Milankovitch cycles and what we'll see
is when you combine precession when you
combine or I should say change in
precession when you had combined that
with changes in tilt and you combine
that with changes in actual a how
circular or how elliptical the actual
orbit is and how that changes then you
might have a a respectable way of
explaining what or some of explaining
why earth is entered into these
climactic cycles over many tens of
thousands of years